welcome back last year's Best Supporting
Actress for the Constant Gardener Rachel
Weisz
Jamin Honsou spent months broiling under
the African Sun submerged in the African
swamp beaten humiliated shot at at 73
alan arkin enjoyed weeks of sweltering
in an old minivan only to be
unceremoniously dumped in the trunk
Eddie Murphy a comic icon had to travel
to the dramatic center of a troubled
musical icon from a previous generation
Jackie Earle Haley a former child actor
had to find something tender in a
monstrous pedophile Mark Wahlberg had to
find it in him to play the kind of
Boston cop who in his own youth had
arrested him 25 times and they call
these roles supporting ones here are the
nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a supporting role
alan arkin in Little Miss French Oh
purple Jackie Earle Haley in little
children Jamin ensue in Blood Diamond
Eddie Murphy and dream girl Mark
Wahlberg in the departed and the Oscar
goes to
alan arkin and little miss sunshine
alan arkin says he almost didn't get the
part because
he was two-barrel he claims it was the
most flattering rejection he ever got
I know you're not supposed to read but I
will be totally incoherent if I didn't
it's handwritten it's short more than
anything
I am deeply moved by the open-hearted
appreciation our small film is received
which in these fragment at times speak
so openly of the possibility of
innocence growth and connection acting
for me is has always been and always
will be a team sport
I cannot work at all unless I feel a
spirit of unity around me so my main
sense of gratitude goes to the entire
cast and crew and production team of
Little Miss Sunshine for creating the
same sense of joy and trust and
community that film that the film speaks
about I'd like to thank the Academy Fox
Searchlight my wife Suzanne my sons Adam
Matthew and Tony for their for their
endless support my representation
Estelle Lee Frank and melody and for the
great teachers I've had throughout my
life both in and out of the profession
thank you very much